dadans quelques secondes. Merci.
- - Je pense que j'aide la CAQ
mamais savez-vous quoi, ce n'est
papas à moi ni à vous à décider,
sisi le gouvernement pense que
jeje nuis, je vais quitter.
- - C'était le 31 mars dernier .
FiFitzgibbon qui répondait aux
ququestions des journalistes à
QuQuébec. Si je sens que je nui.
IlIl est avec nous. Eddy Brandoe
bobonsoir. Est-ce que vous
coconsidérez aujourd'hui que vos
nunuisai et que donc vous allez
ququitter? Je parle votre postea
dédéjà fait méditer même la
popolitique?
- - Je vais rester député de
TeTerrebonne, j'ai été élu par 5
00000 citoyens alors ceci mérite
quque je termine mon mandat et
cocomme vous l'avez dit j'ai
ququitté d'un apport consensuel
avavec monsieur Legault. J'ai
réréalisé quand j'ai lu le
ququatrième rapport du commissae
ététique sur le même sujet, j'ai
réréalisé que j'étais peut-être
popour nuire au gouvernement dea
momonsieur Legault ou à mes
cocollègues. J'ai trop de respet
popour ce qui le gouvernement
prprésentement alors je pense qe
c'c'est la bonne décision pour
totout le monde.
- - Est-ce que je peux comprende
quque vous nous dîtes clairemen:
jeje vais terminer mon mandat,
j'j'ai été élu par la population
mamais je ne vais pas me
rereprésenter.
- - Je ne dis pas cela parce que
j'j'ai toujours dit que le travl
quque j'ai occupé depuis trois s
etet probablement le travail le
plplus exigeant et stimulant que
j'j'ai eu travail. Notamment le
cacadre dans lequel la fonction
esest exercée, mais on a décidé
quque n'était pas conforme alors
jeje ne veux pas non plus
m'm'imposer et je ne veux pas
nunuire. Si les choses s'existet
dadans le cadre dans lequel je
dodois travailler, on verra mais
popour l'instant je pense que
c'c'est la meilleure décision pr
momoi et pour tout le monde.
- - Je disais que vous aviez peu
cece combat contre la commissaie
àà l'éthique. Elle avait été
clclaire dans ses autres rappors
: : vous deviez vendre. Vous
n'n'avez pas vendu. Monsieur
LeLegault a dit : il allait pere
1 1 million de dollars s'ils
vevendaient. A raison, vous allz
peperdre 1 million si vous vendz
vovos participations?
- - C'est plus complexe que cel.
IlIl faut se rappeler que j'avas
1313 placements dans des
enentreprises privées je suis
ararrivé en poste j'en ai vendu
1111, une qui nettement qu'il
rerestait une entreprise pour
lalaquelle depuis environ un ant
dedemi j'ai demandé à la directn
unun acheteur. Il faut comprende
quque cette entreprise la
rerecherche de capitaux sur une
babase constant. Les entreprises
leles investisseurs seulement
lolorsqu'il y a un point de
réréflexion et que les
ininvestisseurs ont plus
didisponible que la compagnie
avavait besoin qu'on des marchés
sesecondaires. Cette compagnie
n'n'est pas encore sur un marché
sesecondaire. Un jour de mes déà
1818 mois que je voulais dispos.
LeLe reste était disposé.
- - Est-ce qu'on comprend que vs
auauriez pu être obligé vendre
vovous auriez de l'argent?
- - Il y a un contexte à cela. e
dodois avouer que ce placement i
esest problématique représente
ququand même une portion
rerelativement importante de mon
papatrimoine que j'ai gagné avat
lala politique. On fait des
sasacrifices politiques de et je
l'l'ai fait en toute connaissane
dede cause mais ce gain, l'arget
quque j'ai pu gagner à la sueure
momon front, je voulais avoir ue
vavaleur pour cela, la valeur
nonormale.
- - Vous ne voulez pas perdre M.
FiFitzgibbon, vous ne voulez pas
peperdre 1 million.
- - Exact. Je suis sacrifices ms
unun moment donné patrimoine, il
fafaut vivre. Par contre je
vovoulais vendre et c'est encorà
vevendre. Les dirigeants
enentreprises le savent et sontà
m'm'aider à vendre à un acheteu.
C'C'est toujours sur le marché a
m'm'intéresse.
- - Est-ce que c'est réaliste
paparce que vous allez pouvoir
vevendre et revenir parce que si
vovous vendez vous pourriez
rerevenir ministre réaliste?
- - C'est réaliste parce que vos
etet moi ne contrôle pas le
mamarché. Encore une fois, les
sosociétés de privés il y a un
popoint de réflexion. On a vu un
enengouement récemment sur les
cocompagnies de technologie et
c'c'est l'occurrence ici. Il
ararrive un point détection où l
y y a plus d'un disponible qui t
rerequis par l'entreprise il y a
unun point de réflexion sur un
mamarché secondaire. Ça peut
ararriver dans un mois ou dans x
momois.
- - Depuis deux ans, cela dit, .
FiFitzgibbon de en contravention
dudu code étique qui dit à
l'l'article 46 de la commissaire
ététique de la répéter 40 fois
dadans tous les rapports : vous
n'n'avez pas le droit de savoir
dedes parts dans une entreprise
prprivée qui fait des marchés et
ququi fait des affaires avec le
gogouvernement. Donc depuis deux
anans, vous savez que vous êtesn
cocontravention avec le code
ététique.
- - Permettez-moi d'abord de
rerespecte l'opinion de la
cocommissaire et permettez-moi
d'd'abord mon opinion là-dessus
paparce que l'article en questin
fafait référence au marché avec
l'l'État. Ma vision à trois
mamarches avec l'État. Elle paye
seses candidats, et faisant la
papart des impôts et elle
rerembourse un prêt qui avait éé
ococtroyé en 2016 ou 2017. Alors
coconséquemment monsieur Legault
l'l'a dit très clairement à la
coconférence de presse, il n'y a
eueu aucune malversation, il n'a
eueu aucun conflit intérêt. Ça
cocontexte. Maintenant, la
cocommissaire, pour le payer
mamarché avec l'État ou encore
apaprès,, mais je peux vous dire
quque comme ministre de
l'l'économie, jusqu'à ce matin,l
n'n'y a jamais eu aucune situatn
dadans laquelle j'aurais pu être
unun conflit. Aucune.
- - Un comprimé que le simple ft
etet elle prétend qu'il y a un
mamarché, il y a un lien autremt
didit entre cette entreprise et
l'l'État québécois Investissemet
QuQuébec est pas très près etc.,
etet que je te cela vous met en
coconflit avec le code étique.
- - Exact. Effectivement les
acactions... allez-y.
- - J'allais dire de député, ele
vovous demande d'ici jeudi cela,
ilil faut que vous mettiez cela
dadans une fiducie sans droit de
reregard. Elle voulait faire?
- - Absolument mais ça ne changa
ririen. Mes actions mutuelles et
ouou que je les garde laisseront
l'l'appareil. Je vais le faire
paparce que c'est un signe qu'il
n'n'y a pas grand-chose mais je
vavais le faire, absolument.
- - Monsieur Legault a dit : ce
sesera difficile pour lui de le
fafaire parce que s'il veut vene
etet que c'est sans droit de
reregard comme? Il va se retrour
dadans l'impossibilité de vendr.
- - Écoutez, il faut comprendren
mamandat ou un droit de regard.
ToTout ce qu'on sait que l'on
ététait qui sont protégés par ue
titierce partie. Transaction qui
vava se faire. En fait, le point
lele plus important ici c'est qe
d'd'une part je n'ai pas eu de
mamalversation ni de conflit mas
dedeuxièmement depuis deux ans,e
tititre comme les autres titres
quque j'ai vendus, les 11, il et
enencore à vendre actuellement.
- - Ce qu'on comprenait, terminé
llà-dessus, on comprenait que
momonsieur Legault, vous et
d'd'autres : les règles du jeu
dodoivent changer. Ça doit êtren
pepeu plus souple pour les gens
ququi de la qui veulent aller
fafaire de la politique. Mais vs
cocomprenez la réponse que l'on
vovous faisait que beaucoup de
gegens vous faisaient de dire :n
nene peut pas changer les règles
dudu jeu en pleine partie.
- - D'accord avec vous. Je pense
quque monsieur Legault l'a dit :
j'j'ai passé huit ans sur le
coconseil administration de la
CaCaisse de dépôt, était à
nanational comme exécutif était
prprésident d'une compagnie
pupublique je n'ai jamais été en
sisituation de conflit intérêt.
PoPourquoi? Parce qu'il y a des
rrègles qui existent. Je pensnse
quque dans un autre mandat ou
nonotre législateur mériterait e
rerevoir ses règles parce que ce
ququi est important c'est qu'ile
fafaut pas que les ministres
sosoient dans une situation
d'd'abord des conflits! On peute
fafaire de différentes façons. e
pepense que les règles que l'ona
pupues notamment, je peux le die
sosont des règles d'une autre
épépoque alors il faut les ajusr
etet ça va prendre quelques
chchanger parce que ce sera
cocompliqué mais le fait demeur.
LaLa commissaire étique
d'd'ailleurs, c'est un peu
irironique mais la commissaire t
mamalheureusement un mois avanta
papandémie a émis un rapport de
15150 qui demandait de revoir et
pepersonne n'a lu le rapport.